my question is for Jensen Jared Misha
and Mark if your characters yes like
everybody but German well so if your
characters had dating profiles what what
they say
Sam's would be really difficult
it'd be like Sam Winchester tall floppy
hair all past girlfriends have died
horribly
mm and and tall tall again twice a call
if you're interested but be prepared to
sign an affidavit
I think Castiel's would have to say
something about his disrespect for
people's personal space if in full
disclosure because I think that could be
a real turnoff on a first date you know
so tell me about yourself
you should be something like a
disclaimer being like if I look away
it's not because I'm not interested
he always he's always Dean's would be
rolling through town no strings attached
interested similar to my personal fits
must love dogs Muslim talk excessively
that's bad
I don't wanna be hello girls
oh hello boys
love you too don't you that was a little
deep for my liking but I'll take all the
love I can get Jeremy what would you
what would you write what would you what
would your dating profile be come on you
have to do it I wasn't a smart I'm
asking you now will you please ask
Jeremy what is dating basket basket I
think our time is up
Jeremy what would their dating profile
40 cores well I'm really glad you asked
um I don't know I don't have booty will
travel I don't know we will try yeah
amazing
thank you good whitey writes